hey guys welcome to DLM model lifestyle
I'm Daniel and in this video we are
going to talk about the basic 15
clothing essentials for men so let's not
waste any time let's get it into the
video
hey if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and click the
notification bell so you won't miss any
of my other videos no we're going to
talk about 15 basic clothing essentials
for men and if you watch the video until
the end I'll give you a bonus one as
well so let's start with the first one
a white and black button-down shirt
there is very little that won't go with
a white button-down shirt you can wear
it with a suit or with a crewneck jumper
if you want a more casual look I
personally like to wear it with chinos
and then I roll up the sleeves as well
for a cooler look now the black
button-down shirt stream's style and it
is perfect for a night out
the crewneck jumper is a perfect piece
for winter and a future piece in summer
I personally like the navy blue color a
little bit more because it can be worn
with pretty much everything a black or
petrol blue suit if you wear a suit to
work you should always own more than one
now if you're not sure where to start I
personally prefer a petrol blue single
breasted suit because it really does
look great black or brown Chelsey suede
boots whoo now these boots they never go
out of style they are very comfortable
look stylish and can be worn throughout
the whole year a good pair of white
sneakers they're my favorite wear
because of comfort style and they will
go with most of the outfits in your
closet just make sure that you keep them
white. good quality white black and navy
blue t-shirts. yes the white color is
actually my favorite as you can see. a
good quality white t-shirt will fit in
with everything you own. if you buy a
t-shirt try to invest in something cut
from high cotton and you probably know
that lower quality t-shirts suffers
greatly if you put them in the washing
machine and just make sure when you do
buy a t-shirt get the crewneck
if you're not sure where is the best
place to buy some then I'll add my
favorites in the video description down
below. alright the bomber jacket. now the
bomber jacket is always stylish and
relevant throughout the whole year. in my
opinion a simple slim fit jacket in dark
color is the best. monk strapped shoes
now these are one of my favorite made
popular by the one and only James Bond
it is mainly a dress shoe and that is
all that I will personally use it for it
but there's also a lot of people that
wears it with a Jean and a denim jacket
and that's also perfectly fine. no show
socks or hidden socks. guys this is very
important to keep away those smelly
odors from your feet and the sweat. the
sockless style looks great in summer but
you got to use these socks. a good
quality leather jacket now for most of
you that's been following me for a while
know that one of my most favorite
jackets to wear is a leather jacket. it's
even in my logo as well. why? because a
leather jacket will never ever go out of
style. it can be dressed up or down and
it will generally last you a lifetime.
check out my best options in the video
description down below
good quality slim fit black and blue
jeans. jeans are very versatile and they
can go really well with almost
everything that you've got in your
closet. jeans are timeless and easy to
dress up or down. slim fit chinos. they
are a very good alternative to Jeans so if
jeans are not really your thing you can
go for slim fit chinos. I use them all
the time. I personally love chinos
because they look great in casual and
smart clothing styles. now I personally
like to wear them with just a basic
white t-shirt just for a nice casual
look. over coats and pea coats. you will
need a really good-quality coat to make
you look sharp and timeless in winter. in
winter the coat is mostly the first
thing people see so wearing a good coat
that is not too boxy or too long is
very important. in some of my other
videos there's been a lot of you guys
that have asked me hey Daniel what is that
coat you're wearing? anyways the nice P
coat I'll add it for you in the video
description so you can check it out as
well
a good quality timeless watch. nothing
out there can complement a good outfit
as much as a good quality timeless watch
can. so when you go out to buy a watch
invest in a timeless watch. it will
last you for years to come. I've added
my top three picks for you in a video
description below
a good belt your best jeans need a good
stylish belt that fits in with it but
don't go too far especially those belts
with the big buckles you know they don't
look good unless you're a cowboy then
it's fine but you only need two basic
belts a good black one and a brown one
all right now the bonus one is
sunglasses every guy needs a good pair
of quality sunglasses. now when it comes
to style you need to focus on the shape
of the glasses. now if you're not sure
let me give you one basic rule if you go
out and buy sunglasses the shape of
the glasses needs to be the opposite
shape of your face for example if you
have a round face it is generally better
to buy sunglasses with a rectangular or
square kind of shape and then if you're
not sure which sunglasses to get and
not sure about your face shape there are
two type of glasses that generally looks
better with most kind of face shapes
they are the aviators and a pair of
black Wayfarers. I'll add them in the video
description so you can check them out
and a few other ones as well and that's
it guys thank you so much for checking
out this video if you liked it give it a
thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video